make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so we are covering the ending of shazam
right so the the title was basically
canceled with issue number 15. the
issue number 14 this one that we're
covering here is the last one written by
jeff johns and then issue number 15 is
written by somebody else and i don't
really know who it is it's kind of
disappointing
but it also sort of makes sense at the
same time shazam is a really cool title
and he's a really cool character the
issue is that the comic was just plagued
with like delays and inconsistent
artistry and things like that and it was
enough to just kind of turn people off
to it and so people just ended up more
or less walking away if it
received kind of the normal fare of
comic book treatment that we were used
to which is to say
jeff john's writing it consistently and
a consistent artist it probably would
have lasted about twice as many issues
if not more
but the result is that like so many
years before shazam is just not really
able to hold his own title right it's
just one of those instances where it
kind of comes to an end the cool thing
about this is that we do get a really
interesting ending here and probably a
massive cliffhanger i'm kind of curious
to see
what you guys think about this but for
those of you guys playing catch up here
because it has been a little while since
we covered this
what we end up doing here is picking up
with the arrival of superboy prime now
what jeff johns did not explain
is how super boy prime went from being
trapped in the source wall at some point
in time
to being in the monster lands right part
of the seven magic lands which holds
some of the most violent beings that
exist out there in the dc magical
universe we do know the source wall was
broken at some point in time but
we know that superboy prime was trapped
in it at one point we just didn't really
find out how any of this worked and we
still don't right we still don't really
get an explanation in terms of what
happened
between the time the superboy prime
escape the source wall and the time that
he ended up in the in the monster lands
right we just simply know he was being
being held there as a prisoner at some
point now the other part of this
is mr mind as we know that that we had
billy batson's father who basically
showed up on his doorstep one day
looking for a son and looking to
basically reunite more recently we
learned that mr mind was in possession
of billy batson's father and so the idea
was that he wanted to use him as his own
host
so that billy would basically share his
power with his father which mr mind knew
he would inevitably do
and then mr mine would basically be in
possession of the power of shazam and
use it for his own ends and that's
really what happened here when billy
batson became aware of that he basically
used a shrinking spell and then went
inside his father's own head to
basically face off against mr mind and
the battle is not it's not anything
grandiose right it's not a great big
huge battle like what we saw during
final crisis or infinite crisis where he
was like consuming universes or
something like that it really isn't
anything like that instead it's it's
pretty small you know shazam showing up
here
he faces off against against mr mind mr
mine uses a few magic tricks here and
there and manages to get the upper hand
on billy occasionally but the big thing
about this is that mr mine tries to play
on billy's
view of his father in the sense that
mind basically says your father would
never have been here had i not brought
him here right that
basically the whole reason why billy
batson's father's here is because
somewhere along the line mr mind
possessed him and mr mine
brought him here right he basically
drove him to be here we'll get a little
more detail about that later on but
basically he's like your father doesn't
love you or your father doesn't love you
and he never really did
now on the surface this looks like mr
mind quite literally playing mind games
with billy batson
billy doesn't really fall for it and for
the most part goes and attacks mr mind
and once he basically destroys his voice
box mr mind can't really use any spells
because he can't actually speak
and this leads to you know billy batson
basically overpowering him and for the
most part taking out mr mine now when
that happens you end up having all these
different members of the monster lands
who basically collapse
save for superboy prime right he's the
only one that's kind of left standing
here
and so with all the other shazam family
members there along with black adam you
have a billy batson who basically
escapes he uses a spell book he brings
himself back to his normal size and then
super boy prime jumps in
now super boy prime immediately faces
off against the shazam family and
basically takes them all out but the
funny thing about this is that none of
them know who superboy prime is
and billy batson doesn't know who he is
now there's an existing theory that's
going around
on the internet that basically says that
this entire shazam rebirth run
takes place after doomsday clock and for
the most part superboy prime did have a
little bit of post-flashpoint action but
for the most part he hasn't really come
across billy batson yet and so in the
post flashpoint universe what it looks
like
is billy batson doesn't know who
superboy prime is despite the fact that
before the events of flashpoint
superboy prime fought pretty much all
the superhero teams and wrecked them by
himself
[Laughter]
wrecked all of them by himself right it
took the combined efforts of like all
the flashes to run him into the speed
force and keep him trapped and then he
basically escaped right he ended up
getting out of uh you know through
unexplained means and then they had to
fly
it took two superman flying him through
a red sun and then crashing him onto a
planet and then he was taken prisoner by
the green lanterns uh there's a lot of a
lot of history there
between superboy prime and the superhero
community but he basically overpowers
shazam the other thing that i want to
point out here
is that superboy prime is likely in a
weakened state here and the reason why
is because he when he was in the monster
lands and he was being kept prisoner
there was a red sun orb there that was
keeping his power suppressed and for the
most part like any other kryptonian out
there despite the fact that there are
weaknesses that kryptonians normally
have
that super boy and prime doesn't have
he's been exposed to a red sun
all this time it takes time for his
energy to start building up so i would
say had this fight taken place at a
later period had super boy prime escaped
and then waited a few weeks he probably
would have
overpowered the shazam family quick fast
and in a hurry but
such as it is he's basically in a
de-powered state and so what you end up
getting is that when he goes to face off
against shazam then suddenly you have
black adam who jumps into it right black
adam jumps into the fray and you
initially have like adam who tells billy
get your hands on that book
say the spell you need to say in order
to get everything from the wild lands
back to where it's supposed to be we can
get our world back to normal you know
this this town back to normal but before
they can
superboy prime jumps back into the fray
again so you end up getting
black adam and shazam who actually team
up to face off against superboy prime
and this is cool because one of the
things that you see here is that
superboy prime's power is
actually increasing as he fights and
it's one of those things that you don't
really get to see that often with his
character right he becomes more powerful
as he fights and that's exactly what's
going on because remember throughout all
of this
he's absorbing solar radiation from the
sun right so his powers are increasing
as
time goes on and so what it ends up
taking is really shazam
and black adam both saying the word
shazam at the same time
in order to bring him down now black
adam has reservations about this right
he's like if i say that i'm gonna go
back to being my old self and i'm gonna
turn to dust
right like that's the caveat of black
adam if he ever says the word shazam
he'll basically revert back to an old
man and he'll die
right because he's just so incredibly
old that his normal body shouldn't
really be alive at this point and he
would just kind of dissolve and so where
where this kind of explanation is given
the response of shazam is if you trust
me then i will give you a portion of my
power and i will give you enough energy
to where you could say
shazam and revert back to your superhero
self so you can survive the transition
and so when that happens they basically
both go flying at superboy prime and
shout shazam at the same time and that's
enough magical energy that it basically
you know not really
it doesn't really kill super boy prime
but it effectively knocks him out and so
of course you have black adam who
basically just kind of starts breaking
down
and then billy batson sticks his hand
out says shazam and basically turns him
back into black adam again and you get
this kind of explanation
that's really more of an epilogue that's
one of the things that i really like
about this is the fight between shazam
and super boy prime
ended like that right it ended so
incredibly fast and it's like
kind of disappointing and it was kind of
disappointing in terms of how fast it
ended right like i felt like it probably
should have gone on a little bit longer
but at the end of the day this is not
really a crisis event so it's not really
designed
to have this whole crazy situation
however as i've been told or at least as
i've been seen
superboy prime is gonna face off against
the batman who laughs i don't know if
that's true
but that's supposedly what's supposed to
take place if anybody can confirm that
then let me know down in the comments
section but that's supposedly what's
supposed to happen which i'm actually
excited to see like a super amped up
superboy prime
facing off against the batman who laughs
that sounds amazing like it sounds
so cool but with with everything kind of
going back to the way that it was
supposed to by shazam basically using
using the book to kind of send all the
different monsters back to their own
their own particular realms he also kind
of says that he'll try to help those
realms as best he can right he'll
basically be a superhero for those
different places and so what it also
does is it allows his father to kind of
return back to normal right to go back
to his normal self and this is when
billy learns
that mr mind was right the entire time
that when he goes to to greet his father
his father doesn't know who he is he's
like the last i remember i was in
chicago like why am i here in
philadelphia he's like who in the world
are you right he doesn't recognize who
shazam is and shazam's like i'm just the
superhero resident there was some kind
of an incident and he asked him like you
know can i ask you something about your
son and he's like what like what about
my son he's like your son billy he's
like how do you possibly know about him
and shazam asks have you been searching
for your son and the response with his
father is
no we gave that up a long time ago right
like we weren't really the parenting
types we weren't really getting along i
mean she's an absolute mess
you know but like i'm better off without
him and without that kid and he's better
off without me i don't want to find him
i don't want to know him i don't want to
have anything to do with him and then
basically just starts to go back home
and is where billy batson gets
completely shut down by the fact that
his father doesn't really really doesn't
seem to care about him it's like his mom
you know from the shazam movie his mom
didn't care right his mom didn't care
about him or anything she just didn't
want to have anything to do with him and
that's a crushing experience but it's
you know particularly important here
because where the shazam family
comforts billy bats in the way that we
would expect black adam
almost kind of does the same thing he
doesn't really look at him with anger
the way that he normally would he looks
at him with sadness
he looks at him with a kind of look like
damn man like this sucks man like this
is pretty rough
you know this kid's dad basically just
said like i don't want to have anything
to do with you not knowing it was billy
but he's like i don't want to have
anything to do with you and i don't
really care much about you so i'm just
going to go home go back to my life
whatever my life happens to be and call
it a day and so there's a kind of truce
that's formed here between black adam
and billy stay out of conduct and
everything will be okay basically you
stay away i stay away and that's
basically it we also get a few little
a few little tidbits here and that
superboy prime was handed over to the
justice league that mr tawny the the owl
or i'm sorry
the cat or the tiger rather basically
kind of hangs out with them for a while
and that's basically it
but you end up getting the wizard who's
looking at everything going on here and
who basically says that he now trusts
billy batson right that
he should have always trusted him he
kind of sees the error of his ways and
not really trusting billy the way that
he should have but he also says that
billy's greatest achievement will be the
redemption of the seventh member of the
shazam family and we kind of get this
this point where he says like i can see
it right i can see
all of them gathered together we end up
finding out that at some point along the
line
in the future black adam is actually
going to join the shazam family that
he's going to become a part of that
group now if i'm a betting man
this is because of the black adam movie
right this is the reason why that's
happening that black adam will be an
enemy of shazam they'll fight against
each other in the shazam or in the black
adam film we'll kind of get his origin
who knows who really has any idea how
that's gonna play out but at some point
in the dc cinematic universe black
adam's gonna ally itself with shazam and
that's why you end up having this here
right i don't know with any absolute
certainty but that more or less kind of
seems to be the case right dc comics
basically
laying the groundwork for what to expect
in the uh in the the future of the
shazam
line of movies in in the dc cinematic
universe right so that's basically where
things wrap up guys it's just kind of an
end you know
to this whole thing do i think it's a
bit of a disappointing end yeah
i kind of do i really kind of feel a bit
disappointed with
this i feel like a lot more could have
been done had it been given some
legitimacy right had it been given like
legitimate artists that went on for a
pretty good amount of time i kind of
feel like it was just sort of a
background project being worked on by
jeff johns while everything else was
happening i could be entirely wrong
and i probably am but i have a hard time
believing that if it was a main project
that jeff jones was focusing on that he
could not have gotten a consistent
artist for the story
and it wouldn't feel like a background
story but it kind of does right it kind
of just feels like something that was
out there that dc had done and now
they're finished and now it's canceled
and that's basically it
where shazam goes from here i have no
earthly clue right i mean i can cover
issue number 15 if you guys want i don't
really know what the whole idea behind
it is maybe it sets the stage for what
comes next i'm not really sure but let
me know down in the comment section but
if you guys are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
you